Few things are as important to American
prosperity as how our schools fare
when it comes to teaching science,
technology, and math. Our scores on this
count are middling at best. Meanwhile, a
major international analysis recently
reported on STEM practices across dozens of
nations, including many of our leading competitors.
How did the US stack up?
American students do more math homework
than their peers abroad. In 2015,
seventy-five percent of US eighth-graders
had homework at least twice a week.
That was 20 points higher than the
OECD average. US fourth-graders observed
science experiments about as frequently
as their peers in the typical OECD
nation, and American students use
computers in math class far more than
do their peers overseas. In 2015,
four in five US fourth-graders frequently
used computers. More homework,
plenty of experiments, more computers,
but middling scores.
More of the same probably isn't the answer.
We just may need a new playbook.
How do you think US STEM education
stacks up internationally?
Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.